so we know that the official number of
coronavirus cases is not the true number
because not everybody is being tested
and so globally we have about two
million cases in the United States it's
roughly 600,000 cases but these are the
official numbers and the official
numbers are only a fraction of the real
number of cases and as we do more
testing the official number will get
closer and closer to what we would call
the true number but it still is way off
and depending on which study you look at
it is significantly off so what might
the true number of coronavirus cases be
and this is important because if way
more people have actually had it it
means it's far less deadly it's a far
lower death rate if way more people have
had coronavirus but it also means that
it spreads much more easily and it can
impact what the plan would be or should
be for starting to reopen parts of
society and the economy which Donald
Trump seems determined to do and even
said at yesterday's press briefing that
this week he would likely have some
guidelines or ideas about how that's all
going to happen so let's look at a few
different data points there's a town in
Germany gang gelt and they did a
randomized sample of a thousand
residents they just randomly tested a
thousand people and they found that 14
percent of the people in gang golf had
coronavirus antibodies now this is a
comically cartoonishly high number and
there are a few caveats one is that
antibody testing specifically for this
coronavirus meaning SARS ko v2 it's
still early and it's possible that some
of the people that tested positive for
antibodies have antibodies for a
different corona virus and that the test
is not precisely showing antibodies for
this corona virus combined with gang
gelt being a center of infection so it's
unlikely 14% of the world has been
infected of course if the real infection
rate were 14% in Germany that would
imply as many as 11 million people in
Germany had the virus the official
number is only a hundred
28000 if it's anywhere close to accurate
we're talking about drastically
different infection rates than the
official numbers but there are multiple
reasons to significantly question
whether 14% is really the right number
we have another data point from Austria
Austria tested 1,500 people it was a
representative sample of the population
and they found that looking at a
confidence interval
somewhere between 0.2 and point 76
percent of the population had the virus
now that's a pretty wide confidence
interval because the official case
number in Austria is 14,000 point 12
percent of the population would be fewer
people it's only 10,000 Austrians if you
go to Oh point 76 that's like 67,000
Austrians so again we don't know it
seems that according to this test the
true rate in Austria is somewhere
between the official rate and five times
the official rate very different numbers
than that sample from Germany where 14%
supposedly had the antibodies then here
in Massachusetts we have a totally
different type of test that was done a
sewage analysis this is not an exact
science nobody is pretending that it is
the sewage analysis suggests that a
region here in New England
with 500 official cases estimates that
the real number of cases could be
anywhere from 23 hundred to a hundred
and fifteen thousand and again these are
wacky large confidence intervals this
would imply that the real rate is
anywhere from five times to 250 times
the official number it's almost
impossible to believe that the real
number might be 250 times the official
case number that would imply a hundred
and forty three million cases in the
United States seems inconceivable but
certainly 5x the official number 10 X
the official number may be 20 X the
official number if there are really a
ton of asymptomatic cases
could be possible that's data point
number three and then lastly we have a
study which suggests the detection rate
is 6% so if we're detecting 6% of the
cases that would imply the real rate is
about 16 times higher than the official
rate once again that would suggest we've
had 10 million infections in the United
States instead of 600,000 so the real
answer right now is we don't know the
amount that we don't know about the
spread ability and other factors about
this particular coronavirus is huge and
every day I'm reading preprints of
soon-to-be published peer-reviewed
studies many conflict with each other as
an example there's a new one that
suggests that the way that corona virus
is initially hurting people is actually
by reducing blood oxygen supply rather
than being a primary in respiratory
illness and that what is initially a low
oxygen level in blood is leading to
respiratory symptoms again this stuff in
retrospect we're going to figure it out
as we get closer to a vaccine as we
continue to learn about which
therapeutic treatments will work better
but there is so much that we just don't
don't know right now and that is part of
what makes this so difficult which is
when we say look at the curve look at
how it's starting to plateau and go down
we don't know the effect of whether
there are conflicting studies about
temperature and humidity there's just so
much that we don't know and we will
learn it in retrospect and hopefully in
time for wave two and possibly what will
be wave 3 if you love feeding your
intellectual curiosity but you're always
struggling to find the time check out
one of my all-time favorite apps called
blinka stinketh lets you consume an
entire book on your way home from work
they take thousands of popular
nonfiction books condense each one into
text or audio that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important core ideas and information
from that
it's perfect if you don't have enough
time to do all the reading you want to
do or if you just want to sample a book
before you buy the entire thing I
recently read a brief history of time of
course by the great Stephen Hawking this
is a book that I have been aware of for
so long and other things got in the way
and it was fantastic to check it out on
blinkin
blink east has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different nonfiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25%
off a subscription when you go to blink
is comm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video